les élections départementales le dépôt
des candidatures est clos depuis 16h le
deuxième tour c'est dimanche
et pour ouvrir ce journal des élections
lilian melet d'information très attendue
sur le canton de pont sur yonne
oui sur ce canton très médiatisées où le
front national est arrivé en tête devant
la droite et le ps
on a appris le retrait du binôme du
parti socialiste dominique bourreau et
françoise martin dominique bourreau le
maire de villeneuve la guyard était
conseiller sortant et leader de
l'opposition au conseil général
il a déclaré dans un communiqué face au
risque de faire élire au sein de
l'assemblée départementale un
collaborateur de marine le pen
nous nous retirons et appelons par
discipline républicaine à faire barrage
au front national
enfin autre exemple de front républicain
à genlis en côte d'or le front de gauche
a appelé aujourd'hui à voter pour le
binôme de droite qui affrontera le front
national au deuxième tour
autre point chaud aujourd'hui alliance
l'alliance au noir oui on est là dans un
cas atypique puisque ce canton c'est le
binôme du conseiller sortant communiste
alain philibert qui est arrivé en tête
devant le binôme socialiste de l'ancien
président de la communauté urbaine du
creusot jean claude lagrange pour
s'entendre avec le parti communiste et
sauver sa majorité au niveau département
le ps souhaite le retrait de son
candidat
mais le socialiste résiste au risque
d'hypothéquer le soutien communiste au
niveau départemental stéphane robert et
gabrielle talon avec plus de 27 5% des
voix dimanche le binôme front de gauche
mené par alain philibert est arrivé en
tête du premier tour devant le duo
socialiste lagrange go fichons alain
philibert pointe cette semaine
l'ambition personnelle de l'ancien
président de la communauté urbaine
creusot montceau
s'il était élu conseiller général ou
départementales pardon ça lui ferait
huit mandats
moi j'en ai trois actuellement s'il est
élu conseiller départemental j'en aurai
toujours que trois les jeux de vous le
dis sincèrement on ne peut pas assumer
autant demande
c'est impossible le conseiller général
sortant aurait d'ailleurs vu d'un bon
oeil le désistement de son adversaire
vous le savez comme moi c'est une
tradition républicaine et lorsque il ya
un vote le deuxième se retire toujours
pour le premier ça se fait régulièrement
à gauche et nous voulons perpétuer cette
cette idée qui est très bonne
malheureusement voyez cette fois ci ce
n'est pas possible ce serait un non sens
de faire élire et s'est même pas
glorieux pour lui dire pour la troisième
fois monsieur alain philibert à 100 %
des voix avec une quelque part un score
croupion je pense que je serai le
premier s'il gagne à le féliciter pour
son élection démocratique en déposant
aujourd'hui en préfecture la candidature
du binôme qu'il forme avec l'ancien
adjoint d'alain philibert jean claude
lagrange entend bien faire fructifier
les 26,59 % des suffrages recueillis le
week-end dernier quitte à froisser les
instances du parti socialiste qui ont
choisi de soutenir publiquement le maire
communiste de saint vallier en vue
d'accords dans d'autres cantons du
département
bien évidemment il faut que le jean
claude lagrange hélène go fiche on est
bien se retire et s'il ne se retire pas
nous faisons effectivement le choix
d'investir
monsieur philibert et mme berger
aujourd'hui moi ce qui me fait le plus
de peine c'est aussi bien pour les
militants les électeurs des deux partis
du front de gauche et du parti
socialiste qui quelquefois s'affrontent
de leur dire aujourd'hui tout ça est
rasé vous devez appeler à suivre des
consignes de partie je crois qu on
oublie la première chose essentielle ce
sont d'abord des électeurs qui
choisissent une réunion publique est
annoncée par le binôme front de gauche
cette semaine en présence de jérôme
durain le patron des socialistes en
saône-et-loire et on garde nos bonnes
habitudes et lien entre deux tours aussi
sur les réseaux sociaux
oui ils sont utilisés de différentes
manières ceux qui ne sont plus en course
et en profite pour remercier leurs
électeurs comme le candidat modem de
dijon marianne le viking en
saône-et-loire l'équipe ump d'autun 1 se
lance à fond dans cet entre-deux tours
en nous faisant profiter de son score
avec une belle affiche vous le voyez
pendant que dans la nièvre le socialiste
fabien bazin se remettent en campagne
pour la triangulaire de corbigny
décrivant son quotidien marché porte à
porte profession de foi
et puis un grand habit
des réseaux sociaux le député européen
ump arnaud danjean continuer à échanger
avec les médias parisiens à propos de
l'éventuelle bascule à droite de la
saône et loire cette fois il veut faire
un pari avec le journal l'opinion
nous on va attendre plus prudemment les
résultats dimanche soir
merci et lyon et dimanche dernier grâce
à vous france 3 était la première chaîne
la plus regardée alors des résultats des
élections en bourgogne
merci de votre confiance et de votre
fidélité